what is the perfect amount of time to
write a screenplay I feel like it's a
moving it's a moving Finish Line
unfortunately like I I wrote weather
girl in like four weeks um six-month
rule took me like three years you know
because I kept going and scrapping
things and going back and but I'm very
happy with how that script turned out so
it's like that was probably the perfect
amount of time to do it I think any less
than six weeks is uh a bad idea um I've
written scripts faster because that was
the job um but the script isn't better
than it would have been if we had given
it 6 weeks if that makes any sense uh
but yeah it's a it's a constantly moving
Target and I feel like it it's about
what is the script is this a
collaborative piece of work is this
something that I'm writing for a studio
or is it something I'm writing for me
specifically or their you know producers
involved whose idea and what are we
trying to accomplish right because very
rarely is it just let's write the best
movie we possibly can that really is
just stuff that I do on my free time
when I'm not getting paid for anything
because when I'm getting paid for
something it's like here's the idea it's
due here don't change any of the
locations because they've already built
sets don't change any of the casting
because we've already cast it uh that is
the G there are these restrictions and I
often say that screenwriting is more
about putting a round peg in a square
hole than it is coming up with a great
American movie it's um it's about
dancing around people's expectations and
personalities and
Necessities while trying to keep it
feeling like a movie right and that
that's it's one of those funny things
about doing whether you're directing or
whether you're writing is that the goal
is to make this into something that
feels like if you're sitting in the
theater this feels feels like a movie
you know what I mean um which is a very
funny Target to put on it right of like
instead of just make the best thing you
can it's like yeah but it has to follow
these rules and it has to look a certain
way and it has to feel like this so that
the audience can enjoy
whatever art Artistry I'm trying to
convey but it has to fit in this box
right the in the inciting incident has
to happen on page 15 or they're going to
say it's boring they're not going to
know why it's boring but they're going
to be like is really dragging so um
again it really depends it and sometimes
the more time is not better sometimes
it's better just to kind of let's just
knock this
out and not go back to the Maharaja
every single time we send in a draft
because that's my least favorite of like
here's a new draft and then everybody
will have a meeting without me and
they'll come back it's like great love
it except for let's change these Broad
overarching themes and whatnot and I'm
like no no what I'd like from you is
page eight I don't think she'd say this
page 40 this seems like too talky you
know specific let's take this blueprint
that we have which is all the script is
right it's just a blueprint for what
you're going to do on the day and let's
hone this so we're even closer even
though it's probably not very close to
what's going to happen on the day you
know um because things change all the
time interesting so the more time you
have actually isn't any any easier than
let's say if you hey let's do this in 48
hours right yeah the just different
challenges you know but like if you have
no end date in mind basically what
you're struggling with is that nobody
has plans to make this movie right now
right so there's no money being spent
the only money being spent is probably
on you as the writer and so um there's
also the thing that happens on every
script that you're hired to write I
don't care every script will have this
moment of this is not how I saw it in my
brain and they you have to get over that
either it's that you rewriting it
completely because now that they see it
on the page they know how to convey to
you what's in their brain right or you
convince them that what's on the page is
even better than what you had in your
brain because if somebody has an idea
and it's their idea right they're going
to have very specific things about that
but if they don't have the ility to
explain that to a writer then it's
worthless right then uh I'm just going
to do what's in my brain because I'm the
one putting it on paper and if you could
do it then you probably would have put
it on paper but you didn't so now it's
my job how do you begin a
screenplay um you know it's just it's
one foot in front of the other right uh
I tend to I don't really like outlining
um that's not if it I have my brothers I
don't I'm sorry I'm hang my mic if I
have have my brothers I don't outline I
just tear into it and I start from the
beginning and there are times where I
will skip a section if I feel like it's
um going to slow me down or I don't know
how to address it yet and I'll go to the
next section with the idea of I'm going
to come back around um but I usually
start with a big beginning you know I
feel like every screenplay no matter
what type of movie it is needs to have
an opening that grabs you um and so
that's usually what I start with what's
the essence of this film what is the
what would the opening sequence that
would
satisfy a super fan of whatever this
movie is right if if it's a uh if it's a
drama if it's an action movie you know I
I got the the writing job for the
American P girls Rules by doing a big
comedic set piece you know where you
kind of take all the different aspects
you know it's a teen romcom sex comedy
uh with physical comedy and you know
we're just going to do a big set piece
um and that's what got me the job you
know was I just wrote like a 10-page
opener um and that's where I start just
the beginning try to open with a bang I
always think of James Bond movies they
always open with an action sequence in
the middle usually in the middle of
what's happening so that the the people
in the movie theater kind of catching up
you know in the the opening three or
four minutes of like who's the bad guy
what's going on blah blah blah and I
just try to do that for every type of
movie um yeah that's where I start right
at the
beginning how important are
ideas uh yeah I mean they're super
important you know it's like ideas um I
think all across the Spectrum they're
important right obviously in uh
screenwriting ideas Big Ideas different
ideas different ways to go about things
um different ways to achieve what other
movies have done but through a different
path right but as a director I've really
become I really embrace the actor's
ideas of what they come in thinking
about like I never get tired of an actor
coming to me and being like studied the
script had an idea or had a question
that led to an idea and you know most of
the time it's like what what does this
person do for a living I'm like I don't
know
what do you think they do for a living
you know it's like we don't ever talk
about their work in this movie so but I
love that I love people coming in with
their own creative juices flowing and
you know maybe it works or maybe it
doesn't but it's so important to the
process that the DP has his own creative
ideas on how to do this that the
composer does that the actors do
certainly and the you know screenwriter
and the director and we can all have
these um big basically writers room
sessions about everything from the whole
movie to the score to this character to
how this character deals with grief you
know all of that stuff is very important
and it only works if everybody brings in
their own ideas if everybody does their
homework and has the courage but also is
allowed to be creative and have these
conversations I I some directors um some
sets aren't that kind of set where you
can come in and say I was just thinking
maybe I don't know she's has an English
accent I don't know that's a bad example
but you know what I mean it's like there
are some sets where it's they're like
absolutely not get out of here with this
idea and there are other sets where it'd
be like well why would that be and how
do we get there and some of the best
aspects of the movies that I've made
have been someone else's idea of like
what would be cool this would be cool or
this would be funny or this you know
invariably the rule of my career is the
funniest line in the movie is not mine
it's somebody else came up with it and
uh that has never proven untrue like
it's always in the trailer and it's
always either an improv or a suggestion
from a producer or you know from
somebody else uh but it's never
something that I wrote sounds like then
again going back to flexibility because
you may get notes from a studio no we
don't like this change this but then
also on your own project
picking and choosing if people have
input yeah absolutely absolutely and I
love to encourage my entire team to um
be able to come up to me and talk to me
and it can it can get uh trying because
obviously you're trying to do a lot of
things right and you don't want people
constantly being like hey Blain quick
question quick question uh just got a
quick question but I I've learned that
if I discourage that then I miss things
right and the rule is like the every
fifth question or comment or concern
from somebody is something very real
that I should have already noticed right
uh like I'm thinking about something on
the last film where there was a
continuity issue that nobody had noticed
and we had a very shy young uh crew
member who was really just a PA and she
came up and she's like I'm sorry Blen
but I think that had on that different
jacket didn't she you know I'm like how
did that happen thank you you know uh
but there's always something like that
and that you can't watch all sides all
at once and especially the independent
film I mean hopefully everybody that's
watching this is on a well financed film
that has department heads and you know
all the people below those department
heads are incredibly professional and
but probably you know everybody's on an
dependent film set where you have some
real talent some real experience
surrounded by some real inexperience of
people who just want to learn how to do
this and uh and you got to listen to
people but those ideas they're they're
everywhere and you just have to be
willing to hear them I think what's your
process for generating
ideas um yeah I it's a good question I I
wish it was more uh I don't know
creatively romantic but really I you
know I'll I'll take a shower you know
I'll go for a run I'll uh it's really me
trying to drag something out of me you
know as opposed to being inspired
because normally I'm working on
something and like the something already
exists and I need ideas on how to fix
something overcome a problem just keep
it moving so it's constantly me trying
to like drag it out instead of uh I
always you know make the comparison of
like I'm not the kind of writer who
lights candles and does a bubble bath
and you know um listens to Ena or
something like that to to get into the
creative zone I'm the guy who's like I
got a coffee I have to write three pages
this morning let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's go um so you know I'm not
saying that that's the way for everybody
but for me it is um if I'm really stuck
I'll go uh I'll go to a bar I'll have my
computer out on the the the bar I think
it's because I've worked in restaurants
and bars for so long that I just feel
kind of comfortable there um but I'm
also distracted just enough like you can
watch you know I sit very close to the
server station so I see the the
interaction of the uh the people that
work there and for some reason it's
relaxing to me and I work I can get a
lot of work done doing that and it
became a crutch for a second where I'm
like I need to to go and do this in
order to get the script finished but
then I was away from it for a long time
and I'm like okay I don't need that I
don't need that I can do all kinds of
things but that is the thing that if I'm
really blocked I just I go to a bar and
uh I sit there and uh I sit next to the
waiters I don't know I don't know it's a
weird knock on wood kind of thing I
guess certain libraries are good too
yeah now when when I lived in New York I
would always go to the uh the big
Ghostbusters Library you know the New
York public you know and uh it was
great